all right let's talk about skillful
spirituality this has a lot to do with
you and I and what are main pillars of
our gifts are that we're trying to
deliver into the world with the show
with holding space with featuring these
guests and we wrote in the bio too that
this is love that land so skillfully it
winds power social engineering the
future of the human race or what are
your thoughts about this it's important
and it means a lot to me and I want to
have a discussion about it yeah me too
this is one of the most important things
if not the most important thing that you
and I can work on getting better so that
we can more effectively deliver the land
the gifts that we want to bring to the
world yeah yeah so how do we do this
better because we out of over you know
550 of these shows now we've done a
pretty good job at landing the gift of
featuring the guests in a way that helps
them unleash themselves most fully on
the program and we've had also skillful
work that we've done afterwards now
since you've come on board where we hold
space with them where people are just
able to we're just we just be with their
transformative experiences so we're
starting to we're like we're like we're
leveling up a little bit but there's
still a long way to go to figure out how
to do it even more skillfully because we
just had you know Gary Marcus was just
on our show and
we had a really good time maybe like 90
or 95% of the content was all about
rebooting AI and what he's really really
passionate about and what he knows
really well and then the other about 5%
or 10% of the time was us asking him
questions about spirituality about
source about about the divine about
meaning of life about love about evil
about good about beauty all these other
things where he was like yo I'm not an
expert in those fields I came on to just
talk about a book I came to package the
content into just my book but we also
talked about his like leading up his
other books leading up to the book so
you can't really just isolate one
specific characteristic about someone
but basically we can be better at
skillfully bringing love to our guests
to the point where it doesn't feel like
the world needs this what we're getting
ready to discuss here the world needs
and hopefully our show will be a pioneer
among many in landing this concept into
the hearts of the world we're talking
about we're talking about love and
wisdom you know these kind of spiritual
ideas and you know even those words can
trigger some can trigger some smart
people the word love the word
spirituality the word divinity and so
they need not be used all the time
because more than anything this is about
skillfulness this is about the heart of
these ideas Landing experientially with
conviction in the hearts of people so
that the world changes
yes you know as you were saying that
what came up for me was this
understanding that maybe what we
sometimes use as words is really
important because it can trigger people
away from wanting to talk about the
subject that's why so many people have
started to be like the the G word for
God or whatever like and they like make
it so like they add the baggage to it
they add the trigger e feelings to it
rather than maybe like people just being
more okay with using these words of God
or source or spirit or nature or all
that is or divinity or creation just
interchangeably more so and like I
noticed you use those words a lot you
know you're the you're the captain and
you're leading this show that kid does
birthed out of you and in through
probably through yeah
and you use these words a lot you know
these days you and your flowery shirt is
always talking about God divinity source
and like it's like who are you to you
know you talk about the eyeball war the
eyeball race you know so you're have a
precious well of eyeballs that's
building perhaps so who are you to use
these words with your precious eyeballs
who are you to honor their time and
attention with those words mm-hmm
yeah that's like it's a big purpose of
what this is about
trying to help people unleash their
gifts more fully into the world how
people figure out what their North Stars
are help people get inspired and engaged
about building the future help shine the
guests wisdom
the set into other people's lives around
the world
but Ori just too quickly come back to
that thought that I was sharing was just
that in a sense it really is so
important once we get through this like
45 minutes of talking about like
rebooting AI with like your so my thing
is like then just let me finish just a
thought is that just then that other
last couple minutes if I start with the
word source or the divine or whatever
that like immediately triggers some
people very few actually out of all 550
guests we've had it's rarely been a
trigger for people but it's usually a
trigger in the more positive direction
of sweet like we're gonna talk about
this now but that's why I told you a
little bit before we started it might be
better when we go off subject towards
the end to start with something like
what do you think is the meaning of life
or what do you think is consciousness a
biological phenomenon or does
consciousness come and take its seed in
the body stuff like that because then it
it baby steps them into more
conversations away from their main theme
instead of the immediate just yeah
and so we've dis surgically precisely
figure out what is the most tailored it
has to be tailored to each guest
specifically to where they're at I love
that and that's a problem because like
with Gary Gary it was already like I
only have 16 minutes it has to be done
in this frame
you know usually we try and get our dis
here for three hours so that way we can
actually have some time beforehand talk
to them feel out how much they are
spiritually developed and that way we
can tailor the questions more towards
that at the very end at least and then
we can hold we have our then to hold
space and stuff but when the guest is
here just for 60 minutes it's literally
just the centre part which is the
interview know pre stuff know post stuff
with holding space after or with getting
to today was super interesting because
Gary may be the first person to do this
responded in my experience negatively to
these questions toward the end of your
dialogue with him mm-hmm and so this is
a great time to unpack exactly it's
actually really important that this
happened these are like beautiful little
learning lessons from the universe from
God from source that are just like
literally planted in front of us okay so
pausing your eyes there these are
beautiful little questions from the
universe room got from source already
there you're going in with a viewpoint
with a with a unique reality that you're
choosing yes and when you do that how do
you think that lands with people that's
a good question so basically the idea
would be can we just
say that this is a unique learning
experience without having to add the
words God source creation the universe
blahblah afterward just that this is a
unique learning experience and then
people can feel however they want yeah I
think it has to do with your actual
conviction so like God and source are
just words and you like I love tailoring
the words to the person in front of me
or that the audience is right but then
coming from what's felt and what's
believed in stuff so does that make
sense yeah so then so it's a combination
of us having enough time before the show
starts to feel them out and know about
what level where they're at with what
words to use that are most optimal to be
most conducive to conscious
transformation on the show and then it's
also then during the show live being
able to figure out um also can I share
these something that just kind of came
up this is like you know Gary Marcus is
sitting in front of you and it's like
what's the actual impulse the deep
impulse that's driving you to want to go
there with Gary that is something
something real for you clearly because
this is a great question so it's as
though we have developed a world where
the most first principle question which
is like what is this
why is this year why are we taking this
conscious experience why are we having
this conscious experience that that
first principle question is kind of just
like like put over here and then this is
where we do all of the building of
civilization
yeah and so I'm no longer cool with just
focusing on building civilization
without addressing this first question
which is what is the point of all this
what or who made this is there a
specific reason for it is there a
specific strategy of ways to commune
back with that force that created all of
this
what are the underlying principles the
source codes of that force that made
this and just what is everyone's unique
relation to that first principle thing
that's why we asked that question so
they know they're unique first principle
to relation to that the question is so
heavy culturally it's like why don't we
just start with the individual in his
unique conscious evolution because that
will take them there to that what would
that look like it would look like Gary
sitting in front of me and I care about
this question I that's it's a feeling
it's a conviction
Gary sitting in front of me I'm
sensitive to his energy and what his
reality is like and then I tune in to
what wants to like like how can we
enlighten this dialogue so that Gary
witnesses an idea that is new to him and
considers it and comfortable that's
another thing it's comfortable for him
new experience all comfortable
all those things yeah yeah so well how
so it's like literally we are then
engineers of social dynamics that then
drive people more towards this first
principled question that are sometimes
overly focused on the evolution of
civilization and their contributions to
that aspect which is incredible but
coming back to that first principle so
then maybe the question then for you is
Ori what would be your let's say
approach to someone's life trajectory
like let's say let's take the example of
Gary would it be asking them a specific
question about maybe what has been a
transformative experience in your life
that's led you to this point not even
what would it be uh it would be even
more in the moment and insensate like so
if I imagined about it because I did
just get a sense of Gary I would be like
I'd be like Gary what moves you right
because but because he's a brilliant
mind you know he's written books about
AI so he's a thought leader there but I
want to know what moves him and I want
to bring his energy field into in that
direction so you mean what moves him as
in potentially like like what are his
value sets that get him interested in
the fields that he's writing about kind
of or maybe even deeper it's just like
there's a forget yes he's a thought
leader and that's why you have him on
the show but he's he's just a human
being sitting in front of you and you're
sensing that he's heavy on the AI Baba
and so you're sensing that maybe if I go
what moves you it's like rounding out a
beam like because that's what we're
after right like maybe that's why you
care about asking these questions so
much because you want to round out maybe
the consciousness you feel like
there's a missing something right and so
even more finally there's an individual
human being he's emitting an energy and
I'm have a sense about him and often if
a question like what moves you might be
like in in the moment small surgical
step heart surgery toward a more rounded
being
let's play with that then okay this what
moves you question yeah so someone can
say what do you mean by what moves you
yeah I'd be like um I'd be like cuz with
Gary like I noticed that he had like
there was an openness to him you know
he's like his eyes were like slightly
watery sometimes and like there was like
a brightness to like and so what was
your question again well when when
someone replies with something like
there was for sure a lot of openness
with Gary but when when and he's very
you can tell he's also like with his
kids and stuff that there's just some
softness to like why is there such a
critical push for starting with the
first principles view of building
computer systems I love that and
frameworks I love that and so then that
same thing can be applied to to to our
lives as well as what is this first
principle framework for like why are we
here the question was what about when
they say like what does that mean
oh I'd be like what moves you I'd be
like I want to see you feel something
like I'm curious about curious about
that already is again I want to see you
feel something I think isn't conducive I
don't think so mmm I don't think so if
I'm taking the position of the person
that's being interviewed and I'm already
a little bit like in my head and I'm
like talking about like what I've been
you know putting it together about the
future of civilization I'm I'm probably
not going to be so receptive to like I
want to see you feel something well I
guess it depends on where it's coming
from
yeah what do you mean I want to see you
feel something you know like I want to
see you moved I want to see you feels
yeah like maybe if you said that to Gary
it wouldn't land but maybe if I said
that it
like it was coming from an authentic
place mm-hmm and so that's it anyway
skillful spirituality to be able to
perfectly tailor
our conscious evolution and
transformation of our guests to the
degree that they're comfortable with and
to the most optimal efficiency for both
them and for the audience to witness and
to try and propel more of that conscious
transformation and to me this is this is
so important to figure out like you know
even looking back at that conversation
like what could have I said leading into
that segment and then like like what
could have I done even before if I only
had the one hour what could have I done
that like got me to know that there may
be a trigger that doesn't lead to us
optimal of an outcome yeah yeah yeah
yeah being sensitive to triggers I like
that being sensitive to triggers that's
needed we didn't we didn't know that
that was a trigger and that's gonna be
interesting because again for most
people it's a trigger towards them
talking about like what the relationship
has been like with the divine or with
source or with something that transcends
them but with very few people I mean I
don't even remember times this has
happened before where that question
triggered although also the truth is
that out of the last five hundred fifty
episodes we've really haven't been
asking people at the end about their
relationship with source over the last
five hundred fifty of them know right
I've been talking about the relationship
with source probably for the last I
don't know I don't want to give the
wrong estimate but maybe 100 of the last
episodes since yeah in just the last
couple months maybe and that actually
shows you guys about like my conscious
transformation is like why wasn't I
using this word source or God or all
that is or the ultimate nature of
reality or source code or creation or
universe whatever that why wasn't I
using those words as much I was using
them laozi for a second but just not as
much I wasn't using them as much last
year now i meanwe using them way more
often it may have even just started with
the word universe and then it got a
little bit more towards all that is and
then I opened up maybe more to the G
word and stuff like that and source now
yeah go ahead
not just wanting to bring that to other
people that first principled question
yeah
how does it feel that it didn't really
land with Gary today emotionally
I feel like it's a learning lesson feel
like it's a beautiful learning lesson
how does it feel
emotionally
a little disheartening
I'm like hardcore always looking on the
bright side of life like I'm like a look
at that like slightly disheartening
experience and I'm like oh my gosh
there's so much to learn and grow from
that like I'm so pumped that that
happened so that now I can learn more
from it that's how I live life mm-hmm
and it's made literally all the
difference is doing something like that
changing your perspective towards
mentalities like that make all the
difference huge like I could still
literally be whining about it like an
hour later I could just be whining about
it or I could have this mentality where
we're literally recording a conversation
about how to improve it I wonder if
whining about it consciously if that's
real for you is healthy
and what the world needs I have a couple
mixed feelings there one of them is that
there's potentially something in the
dwelling / griefing / journaling / talk
therapy process Inc of that
disheartening emotion that could be
leading to some sort of profound
transformation but I also feel like
there's a tremendous over doing of those
things that we just listed which then
actually impede on people's ability to
process move on integrate achieve
further goals with what they learned
from the experience mmm so like I'm way
in the other bucket I spend most of my
time on okay like yesterday with Minji
like I cried in this this last hour of
the of those space holding with her and
it was because I had just profound
emotion going through me and that for me
was like I was there with it and I was
cool with experiencing that for like 15
minutes
yeah and so I have those moments too of
when I'm just cool with feeling that
those feelings but like in this
situation to me Gary responding
negatively on our show - you're
questioning toward the end your if you
will spiritual questioning toward the
end is
it's heartbreaking it's it's undesired
it's I agree with those words
heartbreaking undesired I agree with
those words I also let's just see me can
we see how well we can capture this with
words okay all right so I'm gonna
intuitively bring up words and then you
so heartbreaking you an undesired it's
some confusing okay
resume it's [ __ ] confusing it's
frustrating that resonates
it's we say it's laughable for me that's
not real like that's not present from
you but is it for you when it was funny
to me because it showed my inability to
come more prepared to that last portion
of the conversation where if I came more
prepared to bridge into that last
section of questions that it wouldn't
have been so laughable it would have
been right yeah I saw you you know being
vibrant and laughing with Gary when he
said no in the face of adversity I still
carried that which is yeah which i think
is really important to know how to do
but for me that wasn't our truth lot the
laughing wasn't our deeper truth about
that moment and about our vision fair
more on the disheartening the gifts
didn't land yep and so like
yeah
and so
I think there's such a cool way of
viewing this with you using those words
to describe power like that processed
int land and then there's potentially
some sort of unique things to learn from
that going deeper into those emotional
senses then there's knowing that also
the embodied knowing that that didn't
work out and that there needs to be
growth in order for it not to happen
again and I'm like living over here in
the it's embodied and I want to go on
and achieve greater optimization with
that process
yeah because ultimately I know you like
to have these like passionate
intellectual dialogues but when it comes
to those things like the more spiritual
moments you're not looking to be at odds
with our guests that's right you're
looking to bear fruit yeah looking for
their experience yeah and the reaction
was initially kind of like oh I don't
did that that conversation is gonna put
me at odds with other people that may be
tuning in and I don't want to put myself
at odds
which is interesting that we even built
a society in the first place that makes
it so that we can't approach that first
principled question without either
sounding dogmatic without sounding can
answer your question force and then and
then can you feel before entering okay
does that hurt yes
it does
does
they're the most first principle
question has now become something that
we need to like tippy-toe around to not
trigger people
and I want the opposite of that I want
the roaring spiritual intellectual
discourse around the source code around
God source creation all that is nature
spirit the most first principled nuanced
loving compassionate discourse possible
around that subject and whenever it
doesn't land
there's hurt it hurts yeah yeah
why and again like be slow with this yes
why does it feel hurt when it doesn't
land
because we have a goal we have a mission
we have a purpose and we want that to
land optimally to cascade a butterfly
effect of beautiful things happening
like maybe gary feels more comfortable
with that set of questions and then he
talks to his family about the more and
his friends about the more and cascades
even more butterfly effects versus
rescinding further back into being
closed off to it
last thing we want to do is accidentally
trigger people to go becoming more
closed off to it yes yes
what a weird world
just that phrase is so mind-blowing we
can't even talk about why it was created
who was created by you know what's the
purpose of it you know all this type of
stuff we came and talked about it
sometimes like I love talking to people
that are so cool with talking about it
because then I don't have to feel that
weird emotion I don't know yeah but I'm
also really down to feel that weird
emotion because it's part of our purpose
to talk to the different thought leaders
at the edge of the fields that I mean
how real is this hurt for you we care a
lot about that set of questions and
about the butterfly effect and for it
landing and it is it is a real hurt
but again I'm just I'm more on that like
pumped will revive right now like
yesterday with min Jo is more on that
like in the holding space house more on
that like the motion deep inside crying
vibing connecting in a different way and
now I'm just like felt embodied on we go
yeah vibe yeah
like I'm probably most interested right
now in what is the best way to approach
that set of questions to someone that
maybe is a little bit constrained about
expressing themselves around those
questions that is my most interested
aspect to my perspective right now and I
think the answer to that right now
that's coming up is that if someone's
constricted to not wanting to bridge
into that subject set of questions to
play it safely to start by easing them
in with something about a trance what is
a transformative life experience that
you've had or what do you think is the
meaning of life or like how can we
connect to nature more deeply or maybe
like mama talks about with is our
disconnection from nature the reason why
we have all these issues in our world
mom a new one maybe that is the is the
way is to go in with a more softer
chiller don't drop into the don't use
the D word divine when they're not when
they're feeling Dogma around that word
plus when it doesn't land it also
potentially leaves our guests feeling
like like interesting that show is so
much about science and technology and
entrepreneurship but somehow it's also
about religion and spirituality and the
divine and God and yeah I feel like if
we get good at it then it can become
like a unique cultural phenomenon for
the range of influencers leaders to come
to simulation and go into this I want it
to be cool and there's already some
momentum you know in the Silicon Valley
there's all these like leaders who like
to go to Burning Man but that's
off-camera you know but this this could
be the time
and it could be it could be like I said
cool to humbly like give yourself to the
viewers as a leader as a thought leader
it could be cool yeah
us creating space for thought leaders
across different disciplines for come
being on to our show to express
themselves in ways that they haven't
done before and to create that platform
for that style of expression and
transformation and catalyze that and
other people that are watching
hmm
like
think about how many people would be
interested to be a fly on the wall of an
Elon Musk
psychotherapy session you know
think about how much good and impact
that could do like if Donald Trump or T
shipping or Vladimir Putin or Elon Musk
or any of these different leaders were
to Oprah oh yeah I mean she's done some
of that stuff
Oprah's catalyzed that for other people
she's been the catalyst for other people
but it would be great if Oprah was to
herself go full-out psychotherapy
session or musk shipping yeah etc yeah I
agree
like that's one of the reasons why I
think I think I wrote about this like a
couple months ago where I was just like
you know does Donald Trump or do any of
these world leaders at like the g20
summit and whatnot do they cry do they
show vulnerability do they talk about
their deepest emotions with each other
yeah cuz if we did literally do that it
would catalyze more world peace and
harmony faster and the whole idea that
they can't do that because it shows
weakness is some sort of a it's like a
masculine patriarchal projection on to
civilization rather than a divine
abundant motherly unconditional lovingly
wrapping of my energy around you to show
you that I love you and I care about you
now I'm losing resonance with the vision
like we have a g20 summit around the
world where world leaders show up in
suits and ties and then look how excited
like I want to make sure this lands
because if you if it wasn't resonant I
mean I
didn't means I didn't explain it well
possibly and like literally they show up
to the g20 in like a scarcity mindset in
terms of my country has a limited amount
of resources and it needs to do the best
possible trade deals with your country
to make sure my people get the best
possible outcomes and the whole thing is
predicated on these masculine principles
of me being able to fight for my people
and get the best trade deals for myself
and meet a natural vulnerability
whereas if that circle was authentic
relating or holding space or circling or
psychotherapy session catalyzed by
psychedelics or not that holy [ __ ] it
would be instead it would be okay how
can my resources how can the resources
that are on the land in the country that
we live on not my resources but how can
those resources be of best use to
building an abundant future for our
entire world and how can yours in your
country do the same thing tell me about
your childhood tell me about your mom
and dad tell me about their lineage tell
me about who you are tell me about your
connection of God and for everyone to do
that one by one in this g20 and talk
about the divine purpose of our planet
would catalyze a completely different
future that's what the mentality is nice
so did that resume you I feel your
passion and so yes
and that's a major part of the future
like we're sick of monkey politics and
we want to go more towards harmony
collaboration unity and divine progress
maximizing the gifts of all people on
this planet yes right now it's people
fleeing [ __ ] at each other and that's
how it's like a cartoon and people are
fleeing [ __ ] on each other on the media
escape literally another layer of
projection of the g20 fleeing show that
each other is the same thing in the
media scape amplified by 2 billion
people fleeing [ __ ] at each other right
right now imagine if that g20 was
vulnerable holding space authentic
relating you would have a media sphere
that's also vulnerable holding space
authentic relating bringing gifts
forward okay in many ways it does start
in a hierarchy like you can make radical
change from a grassroots mentality of
the skillful spirituality it can happen
from the grassroots these golden codes
updated enough like that yet if you are
to be able to also hit the top of the
hierarchy at the same time you can
accelerate the Ascension process of
everyone yes
versus just trying to do it from the
bottom up yes from the bottom up as me
going door by door trying to talk to
people and from the top down is
literally world leaders starting to
behave more in this harmonious
collaborative vulnerable direction which
then catalyzes the billions of people
that watch them to also feel that way
themselves yes yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah keep going dude yeah it's
good that it went from being like what
does that mean not resonating so much to
being like [ __ ] yeah high five
yeah yeah let's get that that huh you
turned me over
well that's initially why you sold me
also on your vision of holding space
because you were talking about
influencers and world leaders being able
to show vulnerability and yes and that's
where it starts with Gary yeah yes
exactly exactly because honestly you're
so powerful I feel like you could have
brute force like through the Gary
interview with a different result
quote-unquote positive and a testimonial
as well but I almost felt like there's a
timing to today like a readiness for
there's like you're you're opening to a
different route of success in power
which is that of love and skillfulness
which has to do with like open-hearted
I don't know I want to hear you talk
again you're so right that the
trajectory since the beginning of this
show was so much more about talking
heads and it's now become a lot more
about yes this intellectual science
technology entrepreneurship is so
important but who is this artist within
your heart who is this this what are the
gifts within that being that are shining
into the world and what is the what is
the connection of that being with nature
and forces that are greater than that
being and so the fact that that's become
embedded in this it's it's exactly why
we took that step back and didn't brute
force or anything but rather just been
like okay something to learn from here
and we're gonna work on it you know have
a conversation about it live right now
it's a whole spirituality I love it
interesting so it it I think there's so
far three main takeaways for me one is
that it starts so much with one's
ability to navigate the transformation
of consciousness in one-on-one settings
with other people
skillfully navigate spirituality and
transformations and consciousness at the
exact level that the person is
comfortable and ready with first second
is that that can be happened it can be
happening more and more faster around
the world from a grassroots level mmm so
there can be more Ori shapira's and Alan
sock ins popping up around the world and
Sandy Hearts and joyous hearts and
people like this that are trying to do
golden codes or like Serena Malkani
that's doing the sound meditations or
min-ji's eyes that are doing the love
stories so there's more and more of
these that are popping up around the
world so there's this grassroots way of
doing this ascension process and
one-on-ones are in one on 20's or you
know type thing and then there's the
third one critical takeaway which is
that we can rock it up to the top of
hierarchies of power faster on this
genetic fitness landscape of these
different peaks and get there faster and
then be able to go from those leaders
and do some spiritual zapping at the
level of comfortability that they're
ready at and one not which will then
cascade downward through their
organization through all the media
coverage that's pointed at them and
can catalyze a billions of people
conscious ascension process so those are
my big three takeaways yes and for that
first one to know how to precisely
endeavor into that consciousness
transformation that set of questions
with surgical precision and doing it in
a way that can start very gently so that
the person doesn't get triggered and go
really far away off the bat yeah
with Gary I didn't feel
much of a willingness to do something
conscious a conscious process beyond his
usual book and stuff yeah and so maybe
we can be more skillful actually or is
completely right so the ideas that if
you can literally feel maybe that the
person is even in just if you only have
one hour that you can feel that they're
maybe not as willing to venture in there
which if I was more skillful I could
have even just been able to tell in that
our conversation cuz you know reflecting
back on how I was feeling while Gary was
talking
if felt like Gary was really skillfully
navigating the book and not necessarily
going to desire to skillfully navigate a
conscious ascension process towards that
so yeah and that's good that's good Ari
I'm excited to keep getting better at it
really yeah really excited to get better
at it yeah me too
love that land so skillfully it winds
power social engineering the future of
the human race skillful spirituality
yeah exactly because often what wins
power in discussions and in politics and
in networks and systems is
sword-wielding you know sword wielding
and I'm excited to inspire people
inspire and guide as we refine this
people to navigate power through
skillful love I was hoping you say that
skillful love wielding yeah skillful
open-hearted wielding and that just
speaks so heavily to yes the one-on-ones
but also things like the g20 is people
are just going in with the sword
wielding instead of the heart wielding
the love wielding so it's wrap yeah okay
thanks everyone for tuning in to this
episode on skillful spirituality we
greatly greatly appreciate it would love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
blowing what we were talking about let
us know stinking love to hear from you
have more conversations your friends
families co-workers people online about
skillful spirituality about how to come
in with that open love on a one-on-one
basis and tailor it to where they're at
for consciousness transformation as well
as how to do it on the bigger scales on
the world leader scales and support us
you can find our links below
PayPal patreon cryptocurrency design
cool merchants you paid all those links
are below and support the other artists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders the
organizations around the world that you
believe in and go and build the future
everyone manifest you dreams into the
world we love you very much thanks for
tuning in we'll see you soon